welcome back to big mood
everyone it's nice we're all here we're
all here
finally luckily there was everyone was
had some weird schedule issues we were
fighting
uh yeah and steve broke up because jess
was watching steve shower
and i i i lucky i've never seen this
this episode is called would you rather
and i would rather kill myself
today i just wanted to um
play a little game we haven't really
done this yet i love games
and i compiled back when uh i was
completely hunkered down
during uh the holidays i just decided to
compile a list of would you rather
questions and i thought that we could
i was hunkered i was hunkered down it's
another word for getting [ __ ] out
it's not she hasn't and she hasn't i'll
be honest with you guys i haven't had
sex in almost six months and i'm
starting to think my vagina
will
the virginity
um okay so i guess i don't know i just i
got some not safer work questions and
some normal ones and we'll just play
around
i mean it's just conversation starters
you know i don't know what else nothing
to be nervous about guys
what smirk is like you guys should be
scared yeah i have no idea what she
should i start with the sex one or just
like a normal i guess
do you want to go just jump right into
it yes just start off strong all of our
vaginas
need
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it's a vagina vagina i'm going
on two months now because
there was like covenant yeah
man in your hand i know years for this
is the longest it's been since i was 19
years old wow
i have no you're a virgin again right
that's why she told you to go apply yeah
yeah
people get our stickers in the bmv soon
from the b yeah gina you will never get
your sticker
okay let's start off with a weird one
would you rather
send nudes to your boss or to your
parents
boss wow parents because they've already
seen it
your dad was actually thinking well your
dad is included he's not
okay yeah um uh i was an adult
right sexually [ __ ] and then also my
boss i'm my boss though
so oh well pretend you have a boss aka
let's just say one of the guys at jk
films they're kind of you know
i know i was gonna say i'm like if we're
talking about those guys practically my
family like
that's weird so i feel like my parents
would like bathe me if i
became paralyzed or something like that
like they would i'd be comfortable with
them
like if they had to and i would explain
the situation like i have to do this
yeah because
would you rather was propose yeah i'm
making it to my boss
i'm sending it to my boss because i'm
getting that promotion oh yeah there you
go yeah
nice no not my bosses they're like my
brothers she said
jk people oh yeah if i said this to jk
people they would just laugh
i'd be like sorry dude that's fine
honestly they might barf so that too
but they're not gonna like it's not
gonna be awkward or anything it's just
like [ __ ] it whatever
i picked my parents though because one
of them is already out of the picture
it got dark i know yeah if i send it to
my parents i'm literally sending a nude
to my dad
and if i had to pretend i had a boss you
have to pretend to have a dad
tip wow
i couldn't help but i'm sorry we're
allowed to do this because we're friends
no one else [ __ ] comment that no no
but
well yeah that would be my answer so you
basically sent it to your mom
i mean yeah i guess that's probably more
my dad's in the picture still
so my dad could get my nude sure i'm
very uncomfortable why would you ever
pick your parents i don't understand
yeah
all right you're pretty good you're
young
i have a great relationship with my dad
but then like eat when my it's just yeah
i could never
okay i it's hard for me because i if i
had a boss right now and he was like a
scumbag like maybe it'd be easier for me
to be like
uh i don't know like or if my boss was
really hot picture your boss from your
last time you were an employee then
uh i don't know when you're a waitress
or something no
you can't yeah it's still my mouth still
pick my parents even like the
because i had a boss lady at the
hospital and
i still wouldn't want to send my nude to
her i would still send it to my mom and
dad
really and i think because i think for
for opposite reasons because you're
pretty close with your parents
but i'm not so i think with that
disconnect
oh it's easier maybe because like no one
in the general public will
see like it's kind of not really an
exposure
very much and i guess it's like it's not
like i picture my parents receiving it
and being like oh
like they would get and go uh yeah like
you know so
i mean i guess it's like for me it's
like my parents are always going to be
in my life my boss is going to disappear
eventually
you know so it's just like [ __ ] he's
always
has seen it yeah he's been wanting to
bed you for
years gina you just gave emotion that's
so much easier if it goes wrong
i'm suing you for
yeah yeah so say if i was your boss
i'm just trying to get nudes right now
then yeah
right she's very lonely
would you rather finger bang to me or no
i'm kidding
that's not yes
i don't even finish the sentence yes oh
god now that now the rumor mill has
really started it's because like
anything with my parents sexually is so
uncomfortable like i remember my stepmom
telling me like how awkward it was for
her to do someone else to do the taxes
and they
asked her what adamandeve.com is we're
sponsored by them by the way
it's a sex toy website she's like you
know how awkward it was for me to do
taxes and they asked me what
adamandeve.com is i was like why the
[ __ ] would you tell me this
like i just my parents make sex jokes
all the time oh really
really really um yeah i mean like it's
just like
you have those really young parents like
so they they had
me and my brother when they were 22. so
it's hanging out with them is like
hanging out with
friends i guess like it's the same type
of humor
my dad gets a little more dad jokey uh
but yeah they like yeah they totally
make sex jokes all the time
my mom told me my actual my biological
mom said
i don't really care if the men are tall
or not they're still they're all the
same laying down
and i want i cried for a week cried for
a week yeah
you're not happy for them but you're not
still banging no
oh god i'm going to be sick they just
grow up yeah
oh thank you i think i've ever saw my
dad naked i would just
i would just i would join a nunnery he
said a word i did see my dad naked once
it was not
my kids are gonna know we [ __ ] i'm just
kidding
okay i've got another question for you
guys this one
is a little strange would you okay let's
try this one would you rather have a
threesome with your partner or you both
cheat on each other separately
three threesome cheat wow
really really yeah i don't want to show
tips to territorial i think
i don't want to she can't watch that
[ __ ] i think my imagination is too
strong like at least if i see them
together i'm like
yeah i got it i got it better than or
whatever you know yeah okay i can like
kind of
separate it but if i have to like know
that he's out there somewhere banging a
chick
my imagination will go wild yeah i'd
rather not see it
i would rather see because i'm in
control like the threesome be like
what are you doing you are inside me
only you know like at least i'm in
control
wait but is that a threesome yeah in the
threesome yeah she looks suck his dick
or something
wait is it can we pick it's two guys
instead cause
no the three i mean i
honestly because i would never no
because if he was gonna cheat on you he
wouldn't be cheating on you with a guy
how do you know we don't know how do you
know well
we don't judge in this if that's the
case then sign me up for a three
or four with you guys anyways um you're
not our type
i know you guys like dark-haired girls
don't you i knew
[Music]
that's a different kind of pain holy
[ __ ]
can i lick my wounds over here in the
corner no
but yeah like i like i don't want to not
know like what's he doing out there
like what does she look like yeah he's
lying and he's going behind my back
i don't know this is just one time you
either have a threesome
or you guys get to cheat you have your
own little private hall pass oh we
planned this
yeah just oh and this is just one we get
to [ __ ] a celebrity
your hall pass if this is your hall pass
so we both planned this so i could just
dial up marshall
if you could dial up marshall and get
marshall would you rather have him in
the room with steve or
no
do we get to know who who it is for each
other exactly
i just want to know who they are yeah
because if he says oh i want to bang
angelina's
angelina jolie am i cool but it's like
yes but if i don't know who it is and he
bangs like his co-workers
yes then we're going to have a problem
it hurts depending on the relationship
other person okay so this is just a
stranger there's no ties to your life
this is just
not an isolated event so i don't have to
watch it it can be a celebrity but it's
an isolated event and there will be no
ripples in your life afterwards
it's just either oh there will be
ripples after there will be
marshall and becky gets marshall it is
way steve would even agree to this i
know i think he would
he wouldn't no he's so territorial right
he would want to make me happy but he
would not be able to stand that
in that case and i might go with tiff
because i don't want to watch either
because i'm very territorial yeah that's
exactly the reason why because i'm like
if i
like while he's cheating on me and
having his good time i'm
i'm also having a great time so i'll be
distracted
forgive him because i did the same thing
gina
we'd be watching and so they would [ __ ]
her not good
she's like oh that's true that's true
yeah we'd be like this the whole time
you don't think i'm gonna get turned on
i'd be so like
so territorial that i'm like i don't
even want to
even get this going and then when he's
[ __ ] me i'm looking at her
right it's just a power move the whole
time
if we had to choose yeah they're not
getting a romantic night alone
[ __ ] no so you would you rather though
like
endure this horrific power move evening
versus just have your
you gave me a would you rather i would
rather not have either of these
you can't go with the third option i
know so if i had to choose between these
two situations you wouldn't rather have
fun on your own
hell it wouldn't be fun i only want to
[ __ ] one person marshall
okay that's an exception right if i had
if i got to choose
but it wouldn't be that fun because i'd
make him wear a condom because he
probably has
come on he sleeps all around like you
think he has something special
very bad problem probably i feel like
he's probably too private for that
maybe this is hard i think that the the
like if it's like
absolutely no strings attached just a
celebrity whatever okay
he can go do his own thing and then come
home to me
ah yeah what if i end up pregnant with
little marshall baby
oh wow steve would be really bad but
they'd be
[Laughter]
oh man you'd be able to pass it off as
steve's child for sure and
only you would know you'd be like this
is marshall's baby i felt it happen in
my world
my dad's famous wow he actually planted
out the ovulation date
that's when we're having our date yeah i
mean for me it was easy i'm like cool
i'm distracted having a good time he
could go have his good time i don't need
to see i don't even know
that's it i agree i kind of lean more
towards that too because if i see i'll
get angry
yeah yeah i would choose to not be
[ __ ] pissed off right right right
right right yeah if it's like it's one
of those things like we don't know went
off
really yeah i mean yeah in general it's
both going to piss us off yeah
we're going to be pissed either way but
which one will piss me off less
yeah and i don't want to see it because
then i'm going to be stuck with that
image in my head
because then because then you know it's
even if you both get to
right right and there's no mental image
of him
like if i have to see him getting horny
for another girl in front of my eyes
he'd be there like i promise it works i
want to sit there just sharpening my
knife the whole time
it says i wish my gun and just here i
will cut your knife
look at mickey got me i don't know if
you can see it on camera
i will cut you it's the greatest thing
it's so gina
it is okay let's try another one how
about good how about we make it
how about we make it a little bit
awkward okay that wasn't awkward
no what what what my parents saw me
naked
already do you have time for another
question before they add okay
okay would you rather have your spouse
have sex with your best friend
or your worst enemy best friend best
friend
yeah 100 i can't have my worst enemy
going around saying oh yeah victor
henson
or my enemy yeah but can you go around
and look at your best friend after she
feels yeah that's fine because i know
that
she won't [ __ ] him good it would have
been
a matter of what if he enjoys loyalty
okay
take into consideration his husband
reluctantly i'll make sure it's really
bad but this is your husband
i know but my best friend's got my back
yeah yeah so she would have done it
she would have known the circumstances
and she'd be like [ __ ] all right she's
like i'm gonna not be very wet
yeah i'm gonna be floppity fish yeah
just like dead fish yeah dead fish and
plus an awkwardness or flop
she's literally flopping a little too
good with nobody i feel too good
and like okay here's i'm thinking long
term here okay
so if it was my best friend to be
hilarious afterwards because every
because they'll know the circumstances
and then why they have to do it
and it'll be hilarious every time we all
hang out afterwards because i can pick
on him and make fun of him yeah
um but if it's one of those things where
it's like it was done behind my back
and he cheated on me with my best friend
oh at least i know where my best friend
lives so i can burn her house down
right because most of the time you don't
know where your enemy lives yeah
you know so at least i will have this
change the scenario there
yeah yeah yeah i agree
i would say with my worst enemy what why
what i couldn't be friends with you if
you slept with my man
hmm even if you had to but like knowing
that your worst enemy got to
[ __ ] your man yeah yeah that's true
that's too much satisfaction for them
yeah yeah they get to hold that over you
yeah
no can't do that my pride would just
well i know he'll never see her again
it's gonna be easy
how do you know yeah because that's the
parameters of the question wow
she doesn't care because she already got
hers yeah exactly she's
she won't she's a [ __ ] she won't enjoy
it you're like i know my man yeah
imaginary husband she won't enjoy it i
just know that if i was on the other
if i was on the other side i was the
worst enemy and i took something
from my worst enemy i would hold that
over them forever yeah because i'm petty
exactly yeah gina and i think the same i
think in this department
yeah can't do it it'd be so weird like
if literally every time we
say i had to sleep with steve and then
every time we hang out i'd make funny
ways we keep trying to come in our bed
jess
it makes for a very juicy video
um yeah i convince you i'm like imagine
if i slept can i just
come in imagine if i slept with stephen
every time we hung out you had to see me
there
no because like i know that you guys did
it because of the circumstance right and
it's more like it wasn't exactly what
gina said like you didn't go behind my
back and do it
unless the circumstances like you went
behind my back and did it and then we're
not friends anymore and i could like and
it's already your worst enemy
you might as well already pick your
worst enemy and not lose a friend i
don't know i'd rather be someone that i
like
yeah yeah damn i don't know i'm
conflicted
because it'll be someone that you liked
if it was your best friend it would be
something you liked that means
if they went behind your back and did it
you can ruin them with all the secrets
you know exactly
you probably aren't yeah you already
know
for someone to be your worst enemy we're
probably close to them at some point
anyway so you have the same amount of
influence oh that's true
because love and hate is just yeah
you're not going to be a worse enemy
with a stranger
likely unless you're just kind of weird
i'm not someone that i've known
that i know that much though i feel like
yeah same
it's very i've never had a really close
friend turn into a world yes same
you know yeah i've never had like
someone that knows
knows me become an enemy yeah no i can't
give my enemy the satisfaction can't do
it
anna go um [ __ ] it yeah for me i'm
conflicted but i'm leaning more towards
best friend
it just makes more sense guess i'm out
in the desert on this one
yeah i do not want you guys [ __ ] my
husband my imaginary husband listen we
don't want to [ __ ] your husband
i know it's like we're doing you a solid
i feel like it would it would
make our friendship worse if you did but
someone wants to do it yeah
it would mother hurt all right some
[ __ ] [ __ ] he'll never see again
he has to do it and then we move on to
the line
you're assuming he likes it see i'm
going to do you a solid as your best
friend i'm going to make sure he hates
it
and then every time we see each other
you like suck his dick
yeah exactly he'll see me as like uh
repulsive okay because he's like oh she
was so bad well
i know that you're gonna make it the
worst sex he's ever had i'll get a yeast
infection before
like it'll be bad you'll just put a ton
of sugar up in there and make it real
yeasty before
speaking of yeast i like to eat bread
how do you like to how do you like to
get this bread nikki i don't want to
leave my house that's what it brought to
me
like a sandwich already made who could
bring it to you and who can bring us
these yeasty sandwiches oh my god none
other than doordash
we're never going to get ad sales ever
again
listen to these ever please don't um
it's an it's a new year and it's your
same old couch resolutions are here but
this year they might look a little
different
let doordash focus on dinner so you can
focus on the resolutions that matter
or don't or just be a lazy piece of [ __ ]
and still get your food delivered to you
like gina
doordash connects you with the
restaurants that you love right now
right to your door and now you can get
the grocery essentials you need also
with doordash too
you can know that that's the thing now
yeah
get drinks snacks other household items
delivered in under an hour
ordering is super easy just order the
doordash app choose what you want you
guys know how these apps work it's not
very difficult
they have over three hundred thousand
partners in the us
puerto rico canada australia
well not that one sucks sorry and you
could support your neighborhood go to's
or choose from your favorite national
restaurants like popeyes chipotle and
cheesecake fire
factory favorite cheesecake factory for
a limited time our listeners can get 25
percent off and zero
delivery fees i can't stand those
delivery fees yeah you better take care
i mean i know it's a service that i'm
paying for but i kind of don't want to
pay for it so great
um yeah so get the 25 off and zero
delivery fees on your first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code
mood that's 25 off up to a 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code mood
don't forget that's code mood for 20 off
your first order door dash
subject to change terms apply use our
code because that's how the sponsors
know that
we brought you there and that supports
the show yeah
and while it's a new year you need to
upgrade your betting can i just say that
upgrading your betting
is a game changer like you need your
sleep
and if there's we talked about this in
the the like splurge first save episode
you should splurge on your sleep it is
important
get that beauty rest and brooke linen
has some real nice sheets
real nice duvet covers everything i own
is from brooklyn and i used to um i used
to order from them even before they
sponsored the show so
i love them i'm a long time customer it
was started by rich and vicki who also
tried to find
beautiful home essentials that didn't
cost an arm and a leg and when they
couldn't they founded brook linen as the
first direct-to-consumer bedding company
they worked directly with manufacturers
to make luxury available directly to you
without the luxury level markups i have
their lux
set and it is so luxurious
you don't even know it feels like the
hotel sheets yes i feel like at home i
can never get the actual hotel sheets
but these feel like the hotel that's
exactly what they're like they're not
too soft they're kind of a little bit
crispy yeah but like in a good way not
in a scratchy way
yes just like thick and crisp and they
feel expensive that's exactly it
um i feel like for years we were looking
like how can we make our bed feel like a
hotel right
yeah it wasn't really until this set
that it actually matched that
they have over 50 000 5 star reviews and
counting they're so confident that you
will love their products they even offer
a 365 day money back guarantee
that means you could try it for a year
wow and if you don't like it you could
return it
too long you guys are being too nice i'm
leaving so many stains and sending it
back
it's 2021 do something nice for yourself
to start the new year to help you do
that brook linen has a special offer
go to brooklyn.com and use promo code
mood to get 25
off when you spend 100 or more plus free
shipping
that's b r o o k l i n
e n dot com and enter promo code mood
m-o-o-d to get 25 off when you spend a
hundred dollars or more
plus free shipping brooklyn.com and use
promo code mood at checkout
that is a lot i love it
okay let's move on to another question
okay would you guys like to take it down
a little bit to like a normal like
question oh you wanna be [ __ ] weird
like should it be weird but not sex sure
related yeah
yes please please okay would you rather
be forced to spontaneously dance to any
song that's playing anywhere
or fart out loud just once when you meet
a new person dance
dance so like first impression is you
farting out loud
yeah just once though or forever you
have to
you have to be spontaneously already do
that yeah
same grocery stores
imagine at funerals when they're playing
the organ and you're just you have to
like go
back hilarious people need that
but they do they do yeah some comedy in
their lives
and then also you'll look fantastic
because you're constantly doing cardio
oh you're right yeah and you're going to
crush tick tock
yeah you don't find it to be
embarrassing in the in the most
nope concerning moments no i feel like
you'll just be known as that girl like
oh she just has this confusion yeah
exactly
just ignore her it's okay because if i
meet like a hot like if i mean hi my
name is gina nice to meet you michael b
jordan
yeah i'm
so sorry because you're talking about
job interviews auditions yeah
what kind of fart is this is it a stinky
fart
what are those let's just go with those
oh that's easy because and then
then because then i feel like there's
all kinds of situations where there's
music playing and you have to like
child's
work you're trying to work and you have
to [ __ ]
that sounds fun honestly you're selling
me harder on it
right all right but with the fart thing
you could also just figure out ways
to muffle the fart so if it's a silent
one
but like it doesn't seem you could just
meet someone and go oh my gosh you know
like yeah
do like a really loud yell over
something just
i'll know however but
hear me out hear me out god i'm really
good at these situations okay yeah
you are now a public speaker and now
there's a bunch of people in front of
you met for the first time
yeah over and over and over
like for like 500 you know like that's
like in a stadium yeah let's just say
it's situational you have to do a
comic-con signing thing
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ]
maybe like a [ __ ] coming because my
butthole's exhausted right yeah
i'd rather dance yeah i'd rather dance
like i gotta shove a tampon in there
when i go out or something yeah
i wonder if anyone's ever paid a tampon
oh my god wouldn't that be like
gross probably boys right
boys put tampons in their butt just to
see that's their only hole they can try
true true maybe a certain kind of guy
but they're not
so [ __ ] curious i'm pretty sure
someone's done it
yeah dance okay what was your answer
fart i don't know it's just
entertainment
consider the other side maybe i can hide
it but yeah if i could hide i didn't
meet anyone
cuz i could like imagine like not being
able to control never just [ __ ]
relaxing
i love dancing same okay
same it'll keep us skinny yeah it'll
yeah maybe
maybe you guys are right you feel
flexible yeah because i feel like i mean
you're gonna eventually fart in front of
people anyway and i could just [ __ ]
relax
i don't
i've never heard these girls fart ever
right you really haven't
yeah yeah have you have you ever heard
me fart probably
not never i feel like i've known you
guys for years and i've heard you fart
at least
steve's never even heard no yeah casey
well i mean by accident it'll come out
but
for the most part he's never all right
new year's resolutions you guys need to
fart in front of me
no i have tried sometimes i have a
stomach ache it doesn't
i just don't fart you see how
think you might have some issues then if
you can't let any gas out
the rule in the house is to go to
another room and let it out i don't care
if i hear it
i don't want to smell it if it's in
another room it doesn't count yeah yeah
i think this is a justice a slick way of
fulfilling her fetishes she wants to be
in bed with you she wants to support
her yes she said like she hasn't had sex
in six months but she wants to fart in
front of everybody right
so this is so what's going on here i'm
on to you she's broken white devil i'm
on to you
i am a white and i am a devil i am not a
white white devil
i am not a white devil okay um
would you rather have sex with someone
who never
showers ever or someone who never
brushes their teeth
oh toothbrush do i have to perform oral
on the one that doesn't shower it's sex
so whatever
sex is to you for sure the the teeth
this is your husband now this is the
person this is yeah
gum mm-hmm there's ways around it yeah
he can hit it from the back so i don't
have to look the tooth butter that too
you're not done with the tooth butter he
could floss instead of brush
no he's not cleaning his mouth oh damn
that tongue is going to be don't
kiss him could i what sex to you
i could i could have sex without kissing
i could too
but you would never be able to kiss them
ever not just during sex is this a one
night or is this a
let's just say this is your partner for
the rest of your life he either doesn't
shower or he doesn't brush his teeth no
no teeth brushing he's gonna have good
dental insurance maybe you could get him
veneers or something does he at least
get teeth cleaning
every six months no he never brushes
hair never clean
in the middle of the night oh yeah can
we clean this no
no [ __ ] it's still going can you handle
the bo
the onions no i can't at all
the duck butter the dick butter you said
duck no duck butter
oh yeah duck it's called duck butter
i've never heard that i've heard like a
powdered
powdered doughnut you know because it'll
start getting yeasty around the dick tip
cheesy cheese
oh what if he goes down to me with them
teeth yeah so you're basically going to
get a [ __ ] infection
or you never do it with saran wrap we
have some really nice toys because we're
sponsored by adam and eve
yeah um yeah we used our code
i like beer breath so i just have them
drink a beer um
yeah drink something yeah give him a gum
even a gum that's what we were saying
i would say i'm going to have to
disqualify gum because it counts as
cleaning
beer can prove because no dentist you
could give them
gum is dentist approved something
straight from an accident
it's full of sugar zebra stripe is
allowed because it does not clean your
mouth
but think about it every time you guys
take photos and [ __ ] he has to never
show his teeth because they're gonna be
all like that
yellow crusty rotten teeth yeah
even whatever as long as i look good in
the all photos yeah he also he doesn't
smile he just goes like this
yeah because then every time he speaks
you're like oh [ __ ]
hello so not only do do you have to deal
with it when you're having sex but just
in regular life his hot ass breath is
all up in your face
any time you guys speak because you know
like bad breath
travels yeah yeah but imagine someone
that never bathed
exactly like that smells way worse for
sure
some people don't smell bad though but
then like you said theo you
some people's breath doesn't smell bad
you know if you drink enough water just
constantly hydrated i would rather only
smell it when he opens his mouth than
when he
walks into a damn room every time yeah i
can't do that no but there
have you never been around bad breath
where it actually like it's like that
green cloud and spongebob where it
creates a whole cloud in the whole it's
because they don't know how to talk like
where they keep their breath to
themselves yeah because i think like
when i talk i'm almost like
keeping my breath in a little bit like
some people some people breathe
hi i take it across the room my name is
henry
fill it with the air how are you
every morning when casey wakes me up
because he wakes up before me so he'll
wake up go brush his teeth and he's like
ready but i'm still in bed so he'll come
and try to give me a kiss good morning
and i'm like good morning yeah he's
always like bringing it in like sucking
it in he always thinks it's the most
funniest thing ever but i'm like
you're not gonna smell my breath morning
kisses i inhale also
yeah um no because then now i'm
imagining bush
crust dingleberries yeah no oh god yeah
you're right
my old vagina juice on him no no
ppe no nothing yeah i would think the
mouth is maybe a little bit
self-cleaning because like you always
have constant
yeah like a vagina that's true but
except i would say vaginas are way
cleaner yeah vaginas are way better
but it would be a little bit
self-cleaning since there's always
constant saliva
you know like animals water and drinking
food
when you chew food and stuff too it kind
of brushes your teeth yeah just apples
there we go i'm gonna tell them apples
are my fetish and just have them eat it
every time you have sex there's an apple
in his mouth eat this babe yeah eat this
like the harder you crunch on it the
more turned on i am no they could be
like i love it when
it's just like your whole mouth is
covered with an apple slice yeah just
like smile with the apple slice so you
make sure you bite really good okay
orange slice yeah
[Laughter]
all right i kind of want to do like a
normal one if you guys are okay with
that yeah let's
give me your version of no yeah what's
normal this is normal okay
would you rather be forced to move to a
new city
every week or never be able to leave
your hometown
ever that one i was raised in santa
barbara it's beautiful i will live there
forever
i'm trying to get back there i thought
you were trying to get to vegas
no that's just for the inner rim until i
can live in a beach you're just trying
to avoid taxes yeah so i could save up
all my money all my wealth
put in my 401k avoid taxes and then
move to a beach city and retire there
that's my life goal too
but what if i said right now you have to
either go back to your hometown you can
never leave or you have to move every
month well santa barbara was gorgeous so
i would 100 percent move there and um
but you can never travel or leave that's
i can't leave ever
that's fine yeah fine with the hometown
san jose is not too bad and
a family there and i need stability i
need stability too
i mean i know i'm going to go crazy
because i really do love traveling but
the thought of
people never knowing where i am my
parents can't figure out where i am i
don't have a solid address to get mail
people figure out where you are they
have a cell phone it's just every week
no your mail could go to your parents
would just go to the post office or
something
or like people they have four cats they
hate moving
disable relationships and friendships
and work that's that's hard if i keep on
moving
i mean you stream so you could kind of
stream for me but then i won't be able
to see
yeah that's true and then a new city
could just be like
downey uh you know like cerritos
or it could be like or it could be
somewhere in the rain forest of whatever
the [ __ ] with no electricity for a week
and i'm gonna lose my mind yeah is it
like jumanji where it picks for you or
we get to
that's that's a good question how about
it does
pick grants for you i like that dude
what made you say downey
because i just looked at tiff and i was
like i thought you were from downey yeah
i am so
like that's crazy yeah because i would
rather move to
a new place every week rather than cause
i don't really have a hometown i guess
downey would be my hometown but growing
up i
moved so much that for me i'm already
used to it in my lifetime moving so much
so moving every week wouldn't that would
be way more exciting to me than to spend
the rest of my life and i guess it would
be downey
yeah i like familiarity mm-hmm i don't
i'm not used to that
mm-hmm i don't have that like i don't
have like a child that feels like like i
don't have anything to like
i don't have roots you know okay i've
never had that
interesting for me yeah well you have
some
just i'm just roasting everybody with
them
[Laughter]
what did i do today what happened
where did you nicky get laid
fix your woman please steve my god i
actually really like
ombre
wrong brain i'll bring you up that's
really good
that was really good that was like less
than a millisecond you're like
oh no no baby
you've been waiting to point out no i
haven't
she said roots while i was looking at
her hair
and i was like oh
i don't notice [ __ ] but you just said
roots while i was
we could move on yeah
is there something that you're noticing
on all of us that you'd like to just go
ahead and get out
okay well i have been holding back what
i'm
holding in i don't have roots i know
that because i did go well
you don't smell the greatest and i think
it's because you
maybe need some deodorant um
oh man there's a dealer actually yeah i
was like wait a minute oh
we're we're going to make money off of
that yeah that one's okay
if you're afraid if you're afraid of
nikki making fun of you
if you have [ __ ] friends like we do
if you're afraid of nikki calling you
out for smelling like crap
just because she hasn't got laid in two
months and she wants to call you out
make sure you wear a deodorant
specifically native deodorant native
because native deodorant is made with
ingredients you've heard of like coconut
oil and shea butter it's formulated
without aluminum parabens or talc it's
also vegan
and never tested on animals and the best
part about it it also saves you from
getting your feelings hurt by nikki limo
impossible switching a native from an
antiperspirant doesn't mean you'll have
to worry about that midday bo
either there's a reason why native has
over 16 000
5 star reviews it's because it works
with over 10 cents including their
classics and rotation
or rotating seasonals you're guaranteed
to find the one you love
their classic scents include coconut
vanilla which i was wearing yesterday
that's the most popular one lavender and
rose which i really need to get can i
get one of those guys
yeah all right i'm just gonna kill
myself uh cucumber and mint
that one's good i like that one and
citrus and herbal musk
yeah that one smells good the charcoal
one's good too how do i have one
i haven't tried the charcoal one yeah so
good maybe you're more into your natural
scent if so
native has an it has a popular unscented
option
and if you are more sensitive check out
their sensitive collection
that is made without baking soda
sensitive like my feelings right now
no risk to try you're so pretty
having a risk of being a best friend
there is no risk to try there is free
shipping on every order in the u.s
and native offers 30-day free returns
and exchanges in the u.s
so make the switch to native today by
going to native dodo
big mood girls or use the promo code big
mood girls at checkout
and get 20 off your first order that's
nativedeo.com
big mood girls or use promo code big
mood girls at checkout for
20 off your first order and if you want
to
release that tension from getting burned
by nikki so much
uh make sure to check out theragun their
gun is
oh yeah it's amazing i've been using it
so much
yeah me too it's amazing so therigon is
a handheld percussive
therapy device that releases your
deepest muscle tension using a
scientifically calibrated combo of
depth speed and power and it's as quiet
as an electric
toothbrush the gen fourth era gun
doesn't just feel good it gets to the
source of the pain by releasing
tension using theragun's signature
percussive therapy which goes
60 percent deeper than vibration alone
we love when things go 60 percent deeper
with vibrations
yeah this is not a sexual tool deeper
than it's just
vibrational muscle oh yeah
it releases that tension deep i didn't
see it deep
anyway it's been a long time y'all it's
been a long time for us
your legs your quads yeah because how
strong the thing is i don't think i
would want it in your mind
no no no no no no no yeah this is not
appropriate
exactly so whether you want to treat
your muscle attention from working out
an injury or just the stresses of
everyday life like being nicki's
no more and you know what there's no
substitute for the theragun gen
4. also like my friends got like the the
random knock-off
brands on amazon and then they try their
guns and they're like dude this is way
better yeah there's nothing like it
exactly because i actually did have one
years ago and
it it completely hurts like it ends up
hurting
rather than helping so those suck you
have to get an actual
difference it's like cheap mechanics
yeah it doesn't quite work like punching
you instead of like massage like yeah
yeah i don't know it's a weird
combination that just works that their
gun it just
works so theragun is trusted by 250
professional sports teams like real
madrid
and elite athletes like paul george
d'andrea
hopkins maria 250 sports
teams 250 professional sports teams
try their gun for 30 days starting at
only 199
dollars go to theragun.com mood
right now and get your gen 4 thera gun
today
that's theragun.com mood theragan.com
mood dude no lie that thing has been a
lifesaver
because now that like in your 30s things
just hurt for the last reason
you can't turn your neck the same way
yeah for me it's this right now
i've been sitting too much and i've been
using it like on my upper butt area
like where uh gluteus maximus yeah that
but also the coccyx
yeah the tailbone yeah the tailbone
yeah i use it no like i use it around
the tailbone
yeah and it feels great no well they
have different heads too so there's like
a soft head
oh right so i'll put that like directly
on the tailbone it feels great she loves
getting pounded on her tailbone okay
let's go to the next question
feel free to roast me guys feel free oh
you think you think
you're just gonna get it i can't i can't
be that quick please do it anyhow so
nikki just roasted me and
i will never recover but come here i
gotta fix your makeup look how great of
a friend i am
at this party here you go let me see i'm
such a great friend where you're the
best you got it already
i didn't see anything yeah
my eyeliner in the corner has been
smearing there too on this eye only i
don't know what's going on
i definitely thought i had a fuzz there
and went like this
oh so you moved yeah all right
all right hit us would you rather now
marry
okay he's going to be a cheater or
he's going to be a liar oh my gosh
but they're not mutually like they're
but just the lying doesn't mean the
cheating but just like
he's just either lying about everything
or he will cheat
i'm breaking up no you don't have a
choice you have to marry either
a liar or a cheater oh man that's rough
because
um at least lying to me he's not
bringing someone else into our life
and ruining it but damn yeah but if he
is a cheater and not a liar does that
mean he cheats and
immediately goes i cheated oh i cheated
or you know if it comes up he'll tell
you
i mean if you ask if you're like hey
were you really at
work this week well i mean hiding is the
same as lying
so if he's not a liar but he's a cheater
who hides things that to me is it
it is alive yeah i suppose he'll have to
tell you then
yeah i'd rather have that straight
up-ness of it all
probably a cheater yeah [ __ ] because
at least like he like he won't lie about
it when i confront him and i can get rid
of him
but living your life we're not getting
rid of him he's your husband
yeah so if he if we're not getting rid
of him you got a minimum 20.
if he's a liar but not a cheater that's
true i think
i think um i would rather live with that
because i'm only worried about
someone lying about cheating that's your
only like main issue in a marriage would
be cheating what if he lies about the
finances and you guys go broke because
he's special
i manage the finances what if he lies
about uh
like i said literally about any tiny
little last thing you'd be like
hey uh what did you eat for lunch he's
like i didn't eat
but then he has like a full belly never
always about anything
or he just lies a lot i would say a lot
um
so he's capable of like a logical
conversation capable of going to therapy
and fixing this problem
we cannot fix these problems these are
would you rather will they constantly
cheat on me or is it just ones
oh probably often i would say annually
for sure
is the ellie safe about the cheating
sure yeah i'd be another fan
you could still catch herpes and other
things with condoms for sure
no because what if he lies about cute
stuff like i didn't get you anything for
your birthday
because you're ready
he ends up lying about things that he
shouldn't lie about but then things that
he should lie about he's horrible at
those lies
oh then what do you do well what are the
things he shouldn't lie about like like
inconsequential i'm trying to think of
like what
lie if they're not cheating what other
lag would i
like be that mad at that's worse than
cheating
i don't think there's anything that's
worse than cheating so
probably like they took all the money
out of the account and they're like what
happened to all the money
so they're stealers too so that's not
fair because now you're adding because
you know he's a liar and a thief true
okay or
what about or what about wait what if
he's lying about his job though and you
think he's making
two hundred thousand a year but he's
only making eighty thousand i already
make
i already make my own money but i mean
it's still communal household money
that's true but i knew i married a liar
or what if it's things like um like he
ends up
saying that he'll do something but then
he doesn't because he's just always
lying but he he tells you what he
what you want what he thinks you want to
hear because rather than the truth what
if he lies like
yeah i love you i do love you oh yeah
what if that's the lie
that's d i do want to have kids with you
i do get married i can still
cheat so you'd rather pick a cheater if
no oh okay he just lies no he lies but
if he's lying about loving me
then i and i'm not allowed to unmarry
him yeah then i'm probably gonna
go get my needs met elsewhere but how
would you know if he's lying to you
well if i married the liar oh you mean i
don't know if he's lying about that
particular yeah and what if he actually
does genuinely mean it but you just
don't believe him because you're so
useless yeah
exactly you're just so jaded with the
lies it's very stressful
it is if i felt loved like
i think i'd believe him so if he was
still doing my love language but he just
lied about it that reminds me of that
ignorance is bliss do y'all remember
that song from like the 90s it was like
lie to me what the [ __ ]
love me love love you love me
fool me go on and fool me yeah that one
gabby
do you want to get roasted just died
just died
okay we just lost someone in a corner
over there bring in another intern come
on
we're gonna wrap this up man we don't
have time for death
yeah i picked the cheater like i i i've
dealt with an honest tutor
i've dealt with a like habitual liar in
my family and it's [ __ ]
stressful like down to the point where
it's inconsequential like no i didn't
eat your food
it's just like dude why are you lying
like it's just very but at least you
could plan for it you're like i live
with a compulsive liar
yeah so i can't trust anything they say
but they're not going to cheat on me
yeah i might lean towards liar it's
stressful but at least i can
work around it maybe yeah yeah i think i
would pick the cheater
really i'd rather have an honest
relationship
that i know an honest disloyal
relationship well loyalty
oh i guess can be seen in different
terms right
like there's loyalty that's like a very
deep and
inconstant like we're gonna have the
house together we're gonna have these
kids together you'll never
be without anything that you need
maybe once a quarter i'll be in new york
for a business trip and i will cheat on
you but
everything else is you're completely
taken care of and completely loved and
then i use
a girl as a sex toy every now and then
once a year
and then in all other aspects of your
life you're not being portrayed rather
than that yeah
so it's like that one liar that one lie
versus
a a whole host of lies where you can
never really know are you even really do
you even really know this person
not too because if you if you know that
they're a cheater then at least you can
prep for it and you can work around it
you can have your own pool boy
that's true no it's like the rich
marriage
like suburban housewife things yeah i
guess like i just
i guess it's what you those guys are
cheaters anyway what you find in love
like i could never
like i just like to me you don't love me
if you're
cheating on me you're like there's no
way you could possibly love me or
respect me
if you're cheating on me but if your
respect is the lying
yeah the lying thing but it's like how
could you know like sometimes it's just
like
they it's not has nothing to do with me
it's not personal what if it is
personal where it's like just to you
they lie
well i mean if i know it before i just i
just don't think there's anything worse
than cheating to me
like to me you being with physically
with another person
constantly i don't think i could handle
that yeah
damn the cheating one is hard and i
don't like it and i don't welcome it
but i would rather i think personally
feel like i know this person i know
everything that they tell me is true
it's real and our whole life isn't based
on
who the [ __ ] knows what's true or not he
would suss out truth with actions
so whatever they're at whatever they're
doing that's their true nature
but what they're saying may not may be a
lie right
so you're just constantly playing
[ __ ] guess
guess what that's way more stressful for
you to see the way they're acting
like if they're acting like some people
are really good at acting like some
shit's real when it's not
i mean they're actions like so they cook
dinner they spend time with you
they're like they make me feel loved um
i don't really think i would care about
them lying like while they're spending
quality time with me
what if they turn out to be an absolute
stranger and they lied about everything
to you you'll never really know if you
really know a really good detective
true same same don't [ __ ] with me
oh i'm scared i'll let you keep your
little lies but like i'll know
everything about you as you're lying
i'll be like
okay that's it these are really good
just yeah these are really good
they always do like would you brothers
and it's always the same [ __ ] it was
like
yeah yeah these are good these are thank
you do you have a bunch more
just keep it coming and we all had
different opinions yeah which was cool
i could make some more i mean i had a
couple more but i feel like we're about
out of time
next time you're hunkering down next
time see the pandemic does
does wonders for me coming up with would
you rather questions
it's really good exactly so anyways
i guess that's about it for this episode
if you guys um
would like to support the show you can
check out our merch you can
support our sponsors and makes to use
our make sure to use our code because
that's
how we show performance and that's how
we get paid
so if you need any of those things like
doordash or any of those others
there it is i love all of our clients
yeah we we vet all the sponsors and so
we love them thank you very much to the
sponsors and go ahead and leave a
comment because it helps
algorithm if you're on itunes or
whatever
give us five stars all that good stuff
can you guys tell us your answers for
our questions in the comments
and your explanations i want to hear
their their answers true and so new
uh would you rather oh yeah i want to
know who picks farting because literally
no one picked farting and i'm like i
said i would
i thought you said dancing because it
keeps you in shape no i think ultimately
i i lean towards farting
okay and we're gonna end the episode
right there
you can hide it you can totally hide it
all the guys that have the fart fetish
are like yeah
imagine you like you go into an elevator
there's only one other person you fart
you go you did it
that wasn't me or i'll just be honest be
like listen i have this condition i
picked
and would you rather i just have to live
with it if i met you and that was what
you said to me i'd be like i don't i'm
just trying to get to work
come on be like no listen you have to
listen to my problems
i don't care about your fart okay
anyway thanks guys see you next week bye